ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA. OUR QUE HAN VENICE
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY
DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE. LEAN LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO C. R. TO SMITH
STONE TEEN CALAVERAS THE
APPROVED WHAT VOEPEL WALDRON
WARD WEBER WICKS WORD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YES HERE CON. THE MONEY IS
THERE. IN THE NAME OF GOD. THE
MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
MAN THE HOLY ONE OF BLESSING.
GRANT US INNER STRENGTH. AND
ENDURING OPTIMISM. SO THAT WE
MAY CONTINUE TO FIND JOY IN OUR
DAILY LABOR. BLESS US WHAT TO
WORRY AND CONCERN. FOR THE
PEOPLE. WE ASK YOU OH GOD. THAT
YOU USE US TO MAKE THIS WORLD A
BETTER PLACE. MAY THIS BE GOD'S
WILL I MEAN. THANK YOUR MONEY
SIR CAN WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AND SHE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE. PUT YOUR RIGHT HAND
OVER YOUR HEART READY BEGIN I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
NUMBER TWO ZERO REGISTER.
ORGANIZATION. NASAL THANK YOU
YOU MAY BE SEATED. MOVING TO
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL SACRAMENTO STATE
MOVES AND MISTER FLORES SECONDS
THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS
AND PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. LIVING. TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS FOR TODAY'S
ABSENCES ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BERG
SILVA AND CHEN FOR PERSONAL
BUSINESS THIS RACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YOUR MISSION THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BY THAT IS HOLDEN AND BLOOM TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING ITEMS FROM
SYMBOL MEMBER MCCARTY. BY
SOMEONE NUMBER MCCARTY ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ITEM THIRTEEN
A C. R. EIGHTY THREE. AND ITEM
FOURTEEN AJ ARE FIFTEEN THE
CLERK WILL NOT. I MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE THE
SECOND READING. FILE FILE ITEM
ONE THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY TWO WITH
WINDS ALL BILLS OF DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND
FILE ITEMS TWO THROUGH FOUR.
LIVING TO FILE ITEM. FIVE AJ
ARE NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME JOINT RESOLUTION NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER RELATIVE
TO SOCIAL SECURITY. MISTER
COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THE RESOLUTION. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AS YOU
ARE NINE URGES CONGRESS TO
REPEAL THE GOVERNMENT PENSION
OFFSET IN THE WINDFALL
LIMITATION PROVISION FROM THE
SOCIAL SECURITY ACT. THE SOCIAL
SECURITY ACT INCLUDES TWO
PENALTIESTHE W. P. AND THE GPO
WHICH REDUCED SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS THAT TEACHERS AND MANY
OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYEES EARNED
AND PAID INTO. THE W. P. REDUCE
THE SOURCE CODE BENEFITS OF AN
INDIVIDUAL BY UP TO HALF OF
THEIR EARNED BENEFITS. THE GPL
REDUCE OR ELIMINATE THE SPOUSAL
BENEFITS OF A TEACHER WHO OFTEN
LIVES YEARS LONGER THAN OUR
SPOUSE. SINCE 70% 2% OF CALPERS
MEMBERS ARE WOMEN THESE UNFAIR
SOCIAL SECURITY OFFSETS HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S TEACHERS DESERVE
TO RETIRE WITH THE PROMISED
BENEFITS THEY EARNED AND PAID
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AGE ARE
NINE WILL ASSIST IN MAKING THE
NECESSARY CHANGES WE NEED AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO REMEDY
THIS UNFAIR PENALTY ON
CALIFORNIA'S RETIRED WOMAN. ARE
SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER WOULD YOU LIKE
THE FIRST ROLL UP INTO OFFICE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
FOR. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER THERE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTE HIGHS FIFTY TWO KNOWS
HERE THERE ARE NO THAT WASN'T
ABOUT THEIR FIFTY TWO COULD.
LUCIEN WE WILL NOW TAKE A VOTE
ON THE RESOLUTION THE LERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS.
OF THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THERE TO VOTE. BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE I. SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MOVING
TO FILE ITEM SIX AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWELVE TWENTY THREE
WITH THE MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIVING LIVING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS I WANT TO EXTEND MY
GRATITUDE TO ALL OF YOU WHO
SHOWED COURAGE LAST WEEK
AMENDMENTS TO AB TWELVE TWENTY
THREE ADDED URGENCY CLAUSE TO
THE MEASURE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE AMENDMENTS BE ADOPTED IN
THAT THE BILL GO OUT TO PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER WAYNE MR FOR
YOUR RECOGNIZE ANY AMENDMENTS
BUT YOU KNOW SPEAKER- THIS BILL
WAS BROUGHT UP ON THE FLOOR
BEFORE HOUSE WARDEN DEADLINE IT
DIED ON THIS FLOOR. IT FOR
BECAUSE OF THOSE REASONS WE
OBJECT TO THE OR TO THE CLAUSE
AN AMENDMENT TO THE US FOR ROLL
CALL VOTE. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
AMENDMENTS THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEM. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS GO TO
DO THEIR TO VOTE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT OUT
HIGHS FORTY NINE KNOWS FIFTEEN
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED OUT TO
PRINT BACK ON FILE. FILE ITEM
SEVEN ACR FIFTY NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
PORTUGUESE HERITAGE MONTH MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. TODAY IS PORTUGAL DAY
AND I AM PROUD TO PRESENT ACR
ACR FIFTY NINE WHICH
COMMEMORATES JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AS PORTUGUESE HERITAGE
MONTH PORTUGAL DAY IN THE
RECENTLY COMMEMORATED DAY OF
THE AZORES. CALIFORNIA IS A
PORTUGUESE ANCESTRY HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS OF
ALL SECTORS OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE LIFE IN OUR GREAT
STATE. ACR FIFTY NINE REVIEWS
SOME OF THESE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
BUT ALSO LOOKS TO BRING
TOGETHER CALIFORNIANS THE
PORTUGUESE ANCESTRY. MOSTLY
FROM THE AZORES WERE MY OWN
FAMILY HAS ROOTS IN ORDER TO
BUILD A BETTER FUTURE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AT THE PORTUGUESE
BEYOND BORDERS INSTITUTE A
FRESNO STATE FOR EXAMPLE THEY
HAVE CREATED A GRASSROOTS
COMMUNITY BASED STRATEGIC PLAN.
FOR THE TEACHING OF PORTUGUESE
LANGUAGE AND CULTURES IN
CALIFORNIA THE ONLY STATE IN
THE COUNTRY WITH SUCH A PLAN.
AND I WANT TO SHOUT OUT TO THE
NEEDS BOARD JUST FOR RUNNING
THAT BEAUTIFUL PROGRAM. AS WE
LOOK TO GET BEYOND THIS
PANDEMIC THE LOCAL PORTUGUESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND OUR
PUBLIC. UNIVERSITIES ALONG WITH
STRONG PARTNERSHIPS WITH
FOUNDATION SUCH AS BLOOD IN
LISBON. THE GOVERNMENT OF THE
AZORES AND OTHERS ARE
ENCOURAGING STUDENTS TO ONCE
AGAIN ENGAGE IN IMPORTANT
EXCHANGE PROGRAMS TO SHARE
IDEAS. TECHNOLOGIES AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. THE BONDS
THAT THE CALIFORNIA PORTUGUESE
ANCESTRY HAVE BUILT. WITH OTHER
ETHNIC COMMUNITIES ARE OF THE
UTMOST IMPORTANCE FOR THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
RESOLUTION HONORS THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF A COMMUNITY
THAT HAS BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE
TO BE AN INTRICATE PART OF OUR
STATE. A COMMUNITY THAT IS
FULLY INTEGRATED WHILE
MAINTAINING THEIR CULTURAL
TRADITIONS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING ACR FIFTY NINE
RECOGNIZING JUNE FIRST AS AS
BIRTHDAY. TODAY JUNE TENTH THIS
PORTABLE DAY AND THE ENTIRE
MONTH OF JUNE AS PORTUGUESE
HERITAGE MONTH. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR OUR VOTE ENOUGH FOR THE
FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS. THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY MR BE A GOOD WHILE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER. THE SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE HONOR TO DO THE PORTUGAL
PORTUGAL HOME OF THE GREATEST
SOCCER PLAYER OF ALL TIME
CRISTIANO RENALDO. WITH THE
BEST ISLAND OF THE PLANET-
SEWARD DO A- FOR THOSE WHO ARE
WONDERING WHY. MY VERY PORTUGAL
CHIEF OF STAFF WROTE THESE
TALKING POINTS SERIOUSLY
THOUGH- THE THIRTEENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT HAS THE RICHEST
HISTORY PORT PORTUGUESE
AMERICANS THE PHARMACIST
THORTON AND TRACY TO SEARCH ED
THAT SERVE- PORTUGUESE. SOGGY
BREAD I MEAN WE HAVE A
HUMONGOUS POPULATION A DISTRICT
LOT MORE DAIRY FARMERS FARMERS
IN OUR IN OUR DISTRICT AND I
JUST WANTED TO- JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES IN CELEBRATING THIS
RESOLUTION THANK EVERYONE.
THANK MINUTES. THANK YOU MISTER
INCLUDE WHY DR BURKE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED- I JUST WANTED TO
THANK THE MEMBER FROM WINTERS
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD A
WORD HAS A LONG TRADITION OF
OUR PEOPLE WHO SETTLE THEIR
FROM THE PORTUGUESE AZORES. OF
IT ONE OF WHOM ARE HIT THE
FATHER OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER DO
TRAFFIC- SERVED HERE NOT TOO
LONG AGO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DOCTOR BURKE SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
IS AGUIAR-CURRY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBERS WOULD YOU LIKE HER
SHOULDER MACARTHUR'S YES PLEASE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR ALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. WHERE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT THEIR
SEVENTY THREE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. WE WILL PASS AND
RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS EIGHT
THROUGH. TEN MEMBERS WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEMS.
ELEVEN AND TWELVE THERE ARE
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR SO BEFORE WE VOTE ON
THE CONTENT CALENDAR WE WILL
TAKE UP THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES
OF ADDING CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN
RELATIVES OF VETERANS AND
ASSUMING GRAMMAR'S LUCIEN
NINETY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS RELATIVE TO THE USS
LIBERTY DAY. THE CLERK WILL NOW
OPEN THE ROLE TO. MEMBER CHAD
ON AS A CO AUTHOR TO THESE
RESOLUTIONS. MEMBER THIS THIS
VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS TO THE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT THIS IS BURKE CO
AUTHORSHIP OF THE RESOLUTIONS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT THEIR SEVENTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ANY MEMBER
WHICH TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING
AND HEARING AND THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND A CONTENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY CURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTY TWO BY SOME
MEMORABLE WIN WELL TO VETERANS.
BURKE WELL OPEN THE ROLE I.
FOUNDER ALL MEMBERS VOTED. THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY TO
THEIR TO VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY. VOTE I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO THE THANK CALA
ADOPT THE CLERK WILL READ THEIR
MAIN ITEMS ON CONSENT. IRMA
SOLUTION NINETY I THINK NINE IS
ZERO. MEMBER BEFORE WE TO
GERMAN TO MEMORY I WANT TO
NOTIFY YOU ALL THAT SESSION HAS
BEEN MOVED ON MONDAY WE WILL
NOT BE CONVENING A ONE FAMILY
WILL BEGIN MEETING AT THREE PM
ON MONDAY. I HEARD A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ARE REPEATED MONDAY
SESSION WILL CONVENE AT THREE
PM. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS NOW LIFTED AND
WE WILL MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE. YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY I ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AN INTERNMENT IN
MEMORY TODAY MISSPELLED S. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF SON BROTHER UNCLE
HUSBAND FATHER. AND FRIEND. TO
MANY. TORY PARLAN. TORY WAS A
DEDICATED TWENTY YEAR VETERAN
FIREFIGHTER. HIS FIRST
ASSIGNMENT OUT OF THE TRAINING
TOWER WAS IN FEBRUARY TWO
THOUSAND ONE AT FIRE STATION
TWENTY FOUR IN PALMDALE. HE
PROMOTED TO THE RANK OF
FIREFIGHTER SPECIALIST IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND NINE
WELL HE SPENT THE MAJORITY OF
HIS CAREER SERVING THE
RESIDENTS OF THE ANTELOPE
VALLEY OUT OF FIRE STATIONS
TWENTY FOUR. AND ONE THIRTY ONE
IN PALMDALE AND FIRE STATION
ONE TWENTY NINE IN LANCASTER HE
ALSO SPENT SOME TIME AT FIRE
STATIONS AND LOCKING OUT A
FLINT RIDGE SANTA CLARITA AND
CHATSWORTH. TORY TO FIRE
pKNIT TOWN OF ALL GOOD TO SAY IN
DECEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN. OR HE ADMIRABLY SERVE
THE COMMUNITY UNTIL HIS
UNTIMELY TRAGIC DEATH ON JUNE
FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT THE
AGE OF FORTY FOUR. TORREY IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE HEIDI AND
THEIR THREE DAUGHTERS JOCELYN
SEVENTEEN BRAND THIRTEEN AND
THREE SIX. ABOVE ALL TORY
ENJOYED SPENDING TIME WITH HIS
FAMILY AND CLOSE FRIENDS HE
LOVED COACHING HIS DAUGHTER'S
SOFTBALL TEAMS. AND TAKING THE
FAMILY TO THE LAKE OR TO WATER
SKI AND WAKEBOARD. HE WAS A
LIFELONG DODGERS AND RAMS FAN.
WE ARE ALL HEARTBROKEN AND
SHOCKED BY TORIES SENSELESS
MURDER BUT THE RALLYING OF OUR
COMMUNITY AROUND TORY AND HIS
WIFE HEIDI AND HIS DAUGHTERS
BRINGS A SENSE OF PRIDE AND
COMFORT AMONG THE PROFOUND
ANGUISH. LAST SATURDAY TORY'S
FUNERAL WAS TOWARDS FUNERAL
PROCESSION AND HIS FELLOW
FIREFIGHTERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS FROM SURROUNDING
AREAS CAME OUT IN FORCE TO
HONOR HIM. THEY GATHER
TOGETHER- ON OVERPASSES AND
BRIDGES AND LINE THE ROADS WITH
FIRE ENGINES LIGHT SHINING
STRONG AS IS AS PER HIS CARS AS
CARS PASS BY. A SINGLE GO FUND
ME ACCOUNT WAS SET UP BY A
FAMILY FRIEND TO HELP RAISE
MONEY FOR HIS FAMILY AND COVER
THE COSTS THEY MAY INCUR.
ALREADY TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
PEOPLE FROM OUR COMMUNITY HAVE
DONATED. AND ONE OF THE IN AND
IN ONE OF THE MOST MOVING
CEREMONIES I'VE EVER SEEN.
HUNDREDS OF TORIES FIREMEN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. ATTENDED
SAUGUS HIGH. HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION. FOR TONY FOR TORIES
DAUGHTER JOCELYN. AND STOOD
WITH HER AND SOLIDARITY AS SHE
WALKED TO RECEIVE HER DIPLOMA.
CLOSE IN HER FATHER'S FIRE
JACKET. OVER HER GRADUATION
GOWN. OUR HEARTS ARE BROKEN FOR
THE CARLAND FAMILY. AND I ASK
THAT YOU KEEP THEM IN YOUR
PRAYERS. MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
JOINING A MEMORY OF TORY CARLIN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISSPELLED
S. MR HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR FIRST GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. HELEN
AND WILL. OR AS WE KNEW HER AND
WAS AN INSPIRING COMMUNITY
MEMBER THAT USED HER TIME AND
RESOURCES AND SERVICE OF OTHERS.
AND PUT THE ACTIVE AND
ACTIVISTS. SHE WAS ALSO KIND
AND EFFECTIVE LEADER WHO
READILY ATTRACTED NEW FRIENDS-
VOLUNTEERING INTEREST WENT
BEYOND PARTISAN ACTIVITIES HER
POLITICS WERE LOCAL AS WELL AS
PARTISAN AS SHE TOOK ACTIVE
ROLES IN ORGANISATIONS
INVESTING EMPOWERMENT OF WOMEN.
FROM THE WOMEN'S TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY CLUB IN EAGLE ROCK. TO
THE YWCA IN PASADENA MULTIPLE
TERMS AS CHAIR OF THE PASSING A
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN. AND A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS. SHE WAS
KNOWN FOR SERVING AND THE MANY
PROGRAMS FOR CHILDREN LIKE FOR
FOSTER YOUTH SUPPORT PROGRAM AT
ALL SAINTS CHURCH. BECAUSE SHE
HAD ALWAYS TAKEN A GREAT
INTEREST IN SEEING THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE HAD ALL POSSIBLE
ENCOURAGEMENT TO SUCCEED IN
LIFE. IN ADDITION TO THAT.
THERE WERE MANY OTHER PLACES
WHERE HELP HOSPITALITY
ORGANIZING WERE NEEDED. AND WAS
THERE. WHEN SHE WAS NOT
ADVOCATING FOR OTHERS OR
VOLUNTEERING SHE WAS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OCCIDENTAL
COLLEGE BOOKSTORE FOR MANY
YEARS AND A DEDICATED WIFE AND
MOTHER. SHE PASSED AWAY IN THE
EARLY MORNING OF MAY TWENTY
THIRD. AT SEVENTY SIX YEARS OLD
SURROUNDED BY HER HUSBAND
ROGER. ADULT CHILDREN CLINTON
AND CINDY AND GRANDDAUGHTER
JULIET. HER MEMORY REBEL HELD
DEAR TO THE MANY WHO WERE SO
GLAD. AND GLADLY CALLED HER
THEIR FRIEND. I THANK YOU FOR
ADJOURNING AND HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR SECOND
GERMAN MEMORY. MADAM SPEAKER. I
LIKE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF SERGIO BROUGH. AN INNOVATOR
AND WORLD CHANGER. BROUGH
EMIGRATED FROM CHILE AT TWENTY
NINE YEARS OLD WITH FEW
RESOURCES AND NO PERSONAL
CONNECTIONS. BUT HE HAD THE
TALENT AND DRIVE TO MAKE A NAME
FOR HIMSELF. HE STARTED OUT AS
A CONTRACTOR WORKING TO INSTALL
AND REPAIR GAS STATION
EQUIPMENT. HE QUICKLY OBSERVED
THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIENCIES IN
THE FIXTURES AND BECAME AN
EXPERT IN THE OIL INDUSTRY FOR
HIS KNOWLEDGE ON HOW TO MAKE
THE STORAGE OF GASOLINE SAFER.
HIS CROWNING PROFESSIONAL
ACHIEVEMENT IS THE CREATION OF
THE BRAVO BOX. A CONTAINER TO
HOLD GASOLINE THAT INCLUDED
SECONDARY CONTAINER TO ENSURE
LEAKS WERE CAPTURED IN SOIL AND
GROUNDWATER WERE PROTECTED.
THIS EVOLVED INTO WHAT IS KNOWN
TODAY AS UNDERGROUND DISPENSER
CONTAINMENT. THIS INVENTION
RAISE THE STANDARD OF PETROLEUM
CONTAINERS WHICH LED TO THE EPA
ADOPTING A HIGHER STANDARD FOR
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY. HIS
WORK LEADING TO START A SMALL
COMPANY CALLED S. BROUGH
SYSTEMS IN EAST LOS ANGELES
WHICH HAS EVOLVED INTO FIFTY
SEVEN THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
MANUFACTURING FACILITY AND HAS
REMAINED A LEADER IN THE
INDUSTRY HE CREATED. HE PASSED
AWAY MAY TWENTY FOURTH AT
EIGHTY NINE YEARS OLD. AND HIS
SURVIVED BY. ANA MARIA AND
PAULA WHO IS NOW CEO SON IN LAW
BRAD YOUNG FIVE GRANDCHILDREN
AND ONE GREAT GRANDCHILD I
THANK YOU FOR JOINING IN HIS
MEMORY. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN.
MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF A UNIQUE KIND.
DEVOTED AND DECORATED AMERICAN
COLONEL RICHARD LITTLE STONE A
LONG TIME RESIDENT OF PACIFIC
PALISADES AND A VETERAN OF
WORLD WAR TWO THE KOREAN WAR.
AND THE VIETNAM WAR WHO DIED
RECENTLY AT THE AGE OF NINETY
EIGHT. COLONEL LITTLE STONE
SERVICE IN THE UNITED STATES
ARMY SPANNED THIRTY THREE YEARS
BUT HIS DEDICATION TO THE ARMED
SERVICES AND ADVOCACY FOR
VETERANS SPENT A LIFETIME. I
WAS DEEPLY HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
KERN A LITTLE STONE AS THE
FIFTIETH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
VETERAN OF THE YEAR IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. DICK MOVED TO LOS
ANGELES FROM EVANSTON ILLINOIS
IN NINETEEN TWENTY NINE. HE
GRADUATED FROM LOS ANGELES HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN FORTY ONE
AND WENT ON TO ATTEND UCLA AND
UC BERKELEY BEFORE BEING
DRAFTED INTO THE ARMY IN
NINETEEN FORTY THREE. THEN
PRIVATE LITTLE STONE WAS
SELECTED FROM AMONGST THE RANKS
TO ATTEND THE US MILITARY
ACADEMY AT WEST POINT WHERE HE
BECAME AN ARTILLERY OFFICER IN
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. OVER THE
COURSE OF HIS MILITARY CAREER
DICK ADVANCED THROUGH THE RANKS
FROM PRIVATE TO COLONEL.
SERVING TWO TOURS IN GERMANY
ONE IN KOREA AND ONE IN VIETNAM
EARNING NUMEROUS COMMENDATIONS
INCLUDING THE LEGION OF MERIT
THE BRONZE STAR IN THE
MERITORIOUS SERVICE MEDAL. IN
ADDITION TO HIS DUTIES AS A
FIELD ARTILLERY OFFICER COLONEL
LITTLE STONE ALSO SERVED IN
NUCLEAR WEAPONS AND LOGISTICS
ASSIGNMENTS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF THE ARMY AND ON JOINT AND
COMBINED MILITARY STAFFS.
COLONEL LITTLE STONE RETIRED
FROM THE ARMY IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AFTER SERVING AT
UCLA AS A PROFESSOR AND CHAIR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF MILITARY
SCIENCE. BUT SIX CERTAINLY
DIDN'T SLOW DOWN IN RETIREMENT.
COLONEL LITTLE STONE WAS A
CHAMPION FOR EDUCATION HEADING
THE ROTARY INTERNATIONAL
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM OF LOS
ANGELES ROTARY DISTRICT FOR
THIRTY YEARS HE ALSO SERVED ON
THE ORIGINAL BOARD OF DIRECTORS
FOR THE UNITED STATES ACADEMIC
DECATHLON. COLONEL LITTLE STONE
WAS A TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR THE
VETERANS COMMUNITY WAS DEEPLY
INVOLVED WITH THE AMERICAN
LEGION POST TWO EIGHTY THREE.
BUT PERHAPS THE CROWNING
ACHIEVEMENT OF HIS ADVOCACY
WITH THE EXPANSION OF THE
COLUMBARIUM AT THE LOS ANGELES
NATIONAL CEMETERY. COLONEL
LITTLE STONE SPENT OVER TWO
DECADES WRITING LETTERS MEETING
WITH VA SECRETARIES AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS INCLUDING HIS
CONGRESSMAN POLITELY PUSHING
FOR THE PROJECT IS YOU SEE.
BURIAL SPACES WERE RUNNING OUT
AT THE VA AND SOON THERE WOULD
BE NO WHERE TO BURY VETERANS
AND HE COULDN'T STAND FOR THAT.
AND FINALLY IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN FUNDING FOR THE PROJECT
WAS APPROVED AND YET THE
PROJECT STALLED. BUT THAT OF
COURSE DID NOT DETER COLONEL
LITTLE STONE WHO SPENT THE NEXT
TWELVE YEARS CONTINUING TO
ADVOCATE ALWAYS POLITELY UNTIL
THE COLUMBARIUM WAS FINALLY
COMPLETED AND DEDICATED IN
OCTOBER TWENTY NINETEEN. AND
THAT'S HOW  MET COLONEL LITTLE
STONE THROUGH HIS ADVOCACY
BECAUSE HE CAME TO ME AND ASKED
ME TO HELP HE ASKED EVERYONE TO
HELP. AND UPON ITS COMPLETION
CURTILAGE COLONEL LITTLE STONE
NOTED. IT'S IMPORTANT TO ME.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THE NEW
COLUMBARIUM WILL DOUBLE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO CAN BE
BURIED IN LOS ANGELES NINETY
THOUSAND VETERANS AND THERE CAN
CAN REST PEACEFULLY IN THE NEW
COLUMBARIUM. I AM HAPPY TO
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT I HAVE A
PLACE WHERE I CAN REST UP.
COLONEL LITTLE STONE PASSED
AWAY PEACEFULLY THIS MAY ON
ARMED SERVICES DAY QUITE
FITTINGLY. AND TODAY HE CAN
REST UP AS IS A MORE HIS
MEMORIAL SERVICE IS BEING HELD
THIS VERY DAY. AT THE VERY
COLUMBARIUM THAT HE SO
TIRELESSLY ADVOCATED FOR. DICK
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
NEARLY SEVENTY THREE YEARS
DORIS HIS SON RICHARD DAUGHTER
NANETTE SON MARK AND GRANDSONS
COOPER AND HUDSON AND IT IS MY
GREAT HONOR TO ADJOURN AND
KERNEL OF IT LITTLE STONES
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER BROWN
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAME-SUGGESTS BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL- REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. MOVING
TO TODAY'S ANNOUNCEMENTS
MEMBERS I'M ORDERING THE DEATHS
TO BE HELD OPEN FOR THE PURPOSE
OF DR KING AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
ON SB ONE TWENTY EIGHT. THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY JUNE ELEVENTH NO FOR
SESSION- CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY JUNE FOURTEENTH FLOOR
SESSION AT THREE PM. ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
TO RETAIN ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING HEARING OR FOR
THEIR BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISS GONZALEZ MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS AT THE HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
JUNE FOURTEENTH AT THREE PM.